art & shore is speaker number six and
his title for the three minute thesis
how does life sense gravity when we left
Earth and explored space for the first
time astronauts came back with some
problems some of them were easy to
understand our bones are used to
carrying our weight and when we're
weightless they experience less force
they became griddle and soft from disuse
but other health problems were harder to
understand NASA estimates that if we
send a crew to Mars a quarter of them
will come back blinds prematurely from
cataracts some of the healthiest people
we can find on the planet have already
come back with prostate cancer at higher
rates than we expect and higher than can
be explained by the extra radiation of
space there has to be some missing
factor and NASA thought maybe that
missing factor is gravity maybe there's
something about low gravity that our
body is not good at and if we could
better understand that we could improve
the safety of space travel and for those
of us back home maybe we can open up
some new options for treatments but
sending experiments to space costs a
fortune we will never be able to ask all
the questions we want to ask so we came
up with a way to change gravity here on
earth for low gravity if you are
constantly spinning so there's no
consistent up or down you experience up
or down equally in all directions and
this cancels out a lot of the effects of
normal gravity nASA has been using
devices like this for decades to use
cell cultures to look at low gravity
with a couple tweaks we can put in whole
developing fish and the reason whole
developing fish are so important is
there much more relevant than just
clumps of cells for human health and
disease so for high gravity we want to
look at high gravity in the lab as well
so we could see if it's the opposite of
whatever we find in low gravity so I
built a custom centrifuge it's nothing
fancy it's a fan a ceiling fan turned
upside down and we have some adapters
that we 3d print it and we can put tubes
of water on the ends of the blade of fan
in the tubes we can put our fish and so
when the fan is spinning fast enough we
have extra forces on the fish and that
adds up with gravity to give more forces
what we're starting to find is that the
fish developed differently and their
cells communicate differently in
different gravity when they're in low
gravity they have more variation they
have more changes it's like having more
typos and this might go part of the way
to explain why some of the astronauts
have some of these health effects if the
messages that sells send to each other
are less consistent we see just the
opposite in higher gravity where they're
sending more consistent messages what we
think we're starting to get to is it a
picture of how cells communicate to each
other more complex than we thought and I
don't have all the answers yet what I do
have is the tools to finally ask these
questions and what I find most beautiful
about this work so far is that we are
not so different from those fish who
didn't realize they were in water they
just took it for granted that they were
always in water and we took gravity for
granted it is only by leaving Earth that
we learned more about life on Earth
thank you